The first gas-powered car sped through the
streets of Mannheim, Germany at a blistering
10 mph.
Today, we can go a LOT faster… so what's
changed?
Hey motorheads, Trace here for DNews.
Over the last 130ish years, car speed has
come a long way.
As of February 2016, the fastest car you can
buy is the Bugatti Chiron, which is limited
to 261 miles per hour.
(420 km/h).
But why is that car faster than yours?
How did we figure out how to make cars go
faster?
First of all, and it's probably obvious, but
the major reason cars today can move so fast,
is because engines have gotten a lot more
powerful in the last 130 years.
The 1908 Ford Model T had only 22 horsepower
and a top speed of 45 miles per hour (70 km/h).
But today, a base Honda Accord can easily
clear 100 mph (160kp/h) with almost 200 horsepower!
Modern cars can pull more power from highly
refined petroleum.
Today's more powerful cars, can push more
mass, more easily.
But it's not that car engines have gotten
more efficient, the Model T only got 3 miles
per gallon less than the average car today!
Only 14 to 30 percent of the power from gasoline
combustion is used to pull the car forward;
most of the energy is lost to heat and friction.
So, to give cars more horsepower engineers
have either added more engine, or reduced
weight… or BOTH.
It all comes down to the Power to Weight ratio.
That super-fast Bugatti Chiron has 1,500 horsepower,
but needs TWO V8 engines to get that -- that's
a lot of weight.
So, to make the car go fast, they needed to
make it lighter.
The power to weight ratio, is a simple formula…
divide Weight by Power.
Lemme give you an example or three…
A 1200 pound Model T, has 22 horsepower.
It's weight to power ratio is 54.5 pounds
for every horsepower.
That's not great.
A 3000 pound 2016 Prius has 121 horsepower
so has a better ratio of 24.8 pounds for every
1 horsepower!
While the new car does have more power in
a heavier vehicle it is a balance.
By comparison, the Chiron weighs in at 4,400
pounds with 1500 hp: for a ratio of 2.9.
2.9 pounds per horsepower.
That.
Is.
Crazy.
Obviously, it's way fast.
If engineers can get a low weight-to-power
ratio, they'll have a faster car.
But to MAKE a car with a heavy engine have
less weight ain't easy.
Ford mixed the steel on Model Ts with the
element Vanadium to try and make it lighter;
engineers still do stuff like that today.
The Prius uses aluminum, plastics, and special
high-tensile, high-strength steels.
The Chiron, however, was built with ultra-lightweight
materials like titanium and carbon fiber,
keeping the weight down even further and making
for an even lower ratio!
Of course, the Chiron is 100 times more expensive
than a Prius, partly due to that lightweight
material, so there's that.
Tweaks like these are the reason horsepower
has increased 80 percent from 1980 to 2004…
but even then, we can only do so much.
If you have a big engine, and a light car,
you can still only make it go so fast.
And the faster you go, the more air friction
will start to affect top speed.
For this reason, the car that holds the fastest
land speed record in the world -- 763.035
mph (1227.985 km/h) -- looks NOTHING like
a Chiron, or even a car.
It looks like a jet, because jets are perfect
for minimizing drag from air.
But basically, for every pound added either
more power has to be coaxed from the engine,
or a bigger engine has to be built.
The power-to-weight ratio is a delicate balance
even for the muscliest of cars.
Without understanding it, we'd never have
made cars go fast.
Sponsor?
It also takes a lot of effort to keep your
car clean.
Techron by Chevron’s patented Precision
Clean Technology targets and removes deposits
left by lower tier gasolines.
It bonds with and breaks apart carbon deposits,
more effectively than other additive technologies.
Techron gets into the deepest parts of the
engine, where the most destructive deposits
built up, and sweeps them away.
No matter how fast we can make cars go, though,
there will always be speed limits holding
us back.
How we decide speed limits isn't arbitrary
to get me pulled over every other week...
in fact, there's a ton of research on it!
I checked!
Take a pitstop and watch here.
What's your favorite speedy car?
I always loved the Lotus, any of them.
They're so curvy!
Tell me the car you had on the poster hanging
in your childhood bedroom...and subscribe
for more dnews, tomorrow, and the next day,
and the next day…